ALS or amyotropic lateral sclerosis is
one of the neurodegenerative disease
that affects the motor neuron and the
muscle the upper and the lower motor
neuron is affected in case of ALS 50 of
the patient shows cognitive decline and
33.3 percent patient shows symptoms like
desertria and dysphagia that means
difficulty in speaking and swallowing
High throughput sequencing found out the
top mutations in ALS sod1 which
regulates oxidative stress is one of the
top candidate in the screen
mislocalization of protein is found in
ALS for example tdp43 is mislocalized in
ALS which leads to degeneration of these
motor nerve tract
it can be diagnosed using MRI and
investigating the corticospinal tract
there is no cure but supportive
treatment can make life better watch the
full video to know more